Almost.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing in
The 210th chapter, the chapter regarding
the virtues of the day of J, the day of
Friday.
[Silence]
Muslim on the authority of Abi
who narrates that the messenger of
Allah. Wasallam said
the ver the most virtuous of days, the
best of days
upon which the sun has risen is the day
of Jum, the day of Friday.
On that day,
Adam was created. On that day, he was
admitted into paradise. And on that day
he was taken out of paradise. This
narration has been reported by Imam
Muslim.
He says that on that day
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala created Adam
and that is that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
created the heavens and the earth
in six days.
Some narrations indicate that the
beginning of this creation
was on Sunday
and that this creation continued until
Friday.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala chose this day
to create Adam
and he created Adam and Adam went
through stages in his creation.
He wasn't created immediately as a
hearing, seeing, observing creation
speaking.
Rather, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
sent an angel to the earth
and he collected
dirt
from all of the different types of dirts
on the earth.
And he brought that back to Allah.
Abbass
narrates
it's a statement ofb
in
that Allah subhanaha
sent Giblis
to the earth to collect his dirt
and when Jirel approached the earth
the earth responded
in fear. here and said,
"I seek refuge in Allah from you."
Jirelam
heard this cry to Allah. And so he
returned
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then sent
Mik to the earth
and the same thing the earth responded
recoiled
in fear and said
and
responded as responded
and he returned and then Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
sent the angel of death.
The angel of death arrived at the earth
and the earth recoiled once more and
said
and the angel of death responded to the
earth.
And so the angel of death said, "And I
seek refuge in Allah that I not fulfill
what Allah has commanded me to do." And
he collected this dirt from the earth in
spite of its of its pleas. And this this
really tells us a couple of things.
Number one, it tells us that the angel
of death is almost cut from a different
cloth.
He doesn't respond to please. He doesn't
respond to cries for help. He has
been commanded with something and he
fulfills that with a determination
undeterred
and unremittent.
Second of all, how symbolic is it?
How ironic is it
that the one who was sent to collect the
essence of our life is the one who would
later be sent to collect our souls for
death.
How how ironic. Full circle.
Either way, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
created Adam. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions four stages throughout the
Quran of the creation of Adam. He added
water. First it is dust and dirt. He
added water to that. Then he shaped it
in what he referred to as
meaning that he gave it a form and a
figure
and an image
and then he left it and Allah then
referred to it as
that it is a shape
that
has a hollowess to it just like
pottery and it was set to dry and then
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
and then he placed in it a soul
that is of his particular creation
subhanahu wa ta'ala unlike any other
soul.
and he placed it in Adam and Adam.
Form and came to life.
Does anyone know what the first thing
Adam did when he came to life?
[Arabic recitation]
He sneezed. And Allah said to him,
Alhamdulillah
said to him, say alhamdulillah.
And then he commanded him
to go upon a group of angels and say to
them
and this issue of Adam sneezing
this articulates life doesn't it? The
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam tells us
that Allah loves the sneeze and hates
the yawn.
He loves when
the human being sneezes because it's
what? It's expelling. It's expelling
illness. It articulates wakefulness,
life, vitality.
And he dislikes the yawn. person yawns.
Why? Because the person is taking in to
his full and it articulates weakness and
fatigue or boredom and exhaustion.
For this reason, the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam tells us
that if you are to yawn then try to
fight it off
and if you must
then cover your mouth and never make a
sound when you yawn
for indeed if a person yawns and says
when they yawn a shaitan laughs at him
and so
Adam went upon on the angels. And he
said to them,
and they said to him,
[Silence]
and so this is the original salutes and
salutation
of the human being and the children of
Adam.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala chose this day
as our prophet tells us here.
And on the day of J, Allah admitted Adam
into paradise.
He admitted Adam into paradise and he
gave him a few rules.
Really, just one rule.
He said to him,
"Live you and your wife here because
from Adam he created his his wife."
The human being Adam, he's in paradise.
Does he need any other person? Where
does the name insan come from?
The root word, the etmology of insan,
huh?
We have two linguists here amongst us.
So the first is from El is needing
company.
The human being gets lonely without
The other is anen from forgetfulness.
Both of them are mentioned by the
scholars of by the linguists the Arab
linguists that
alinsan is derived from al and is
likewise derived from
there's no reason why it can't draw
its origins from both words because they
have the same they're built the same
they have the same essential letters
and so Adam, he has all these angels
around him. He has all this paradise,
but he's still he's still a little bit
lonely. Why? Because
there is not another human being there
with him. a human being, someone that he
can, someone that he can relate to,
somebody that is cut from the same
general cloth, someone that is
derivative of him. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala tells us in the Quran,
[Silence]
that he created from Adam, his mate, his
spouse.
Why? In order that he would find solace
in his spouse.
Solace in his spouse. And this goes back
to the essence of marriage. What is the
essence of marriage?
The essence of marriage, the essence of
the of the relationship between the man
and the wife is
for solace to be had.
And so when we see disruption in the
household, when we see a wife that is
rebellious to her husband or a husband
that is callous and unnoticing of his
wife, this connection of solace is
severed and broken and the essence and
purpose of marriage is lost.
And so all of the
principles of Islam, all of the rules
and laws of Islam with respect to the
rules and laws of marriage between a man
and wife, they are all founded around
what? Around this core value.
The core value of in order that he will
find solace in his wife.
All rules and laws of marriage are
founded around this because this is the
whole purpose of it. We also notice that
the female is a
is an equal to the male or a derivative
of the male.
Say it. Don't be afraid. The feminist
world that we live in today, we can't
don't say sheh.
Don't say that men and women are exactly
the same. No, they're not.
The female is derivative of the male and
she was created in order to support the
male. This is the essence of the
creation. When we try to flip that or
when we try to raise one as an equal to
the other, destruction ensues. You can
paint it with whatever brush you want,
but at the end failure will be the
result.
The female is not the equal of the male,
not in body. In soul, sure, in spirit,
in worship of Allah, yes.
No soul shall bear the burden of
another.
was right.
Yes. But on this earth
in this context,
the male and the female have very unique
roles.
What makes the most lousy female
the most lousy female? A male.
A male trying to be a female makes the
most lousy female. He will fail at being
both male and female. What makes the
most lousy male?
A female.
She will neither be a male nor a female.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
and he says this,
[Silence]
He tells us that Allah has given some
more than others.
Does that mean that out the gates one is
better than the other? No. It just means
that each one has different pieces of
the puzzle that they can put together.
If they try to use those pieces on
someone else's puzzle, it will not fit.
It will be distorted and grotesque.
The only way a person can reach his
maximum potential is if he plays his
part, stays in his lane. When a woman
tries to be a man, she fails at both.
When a man tries to be a woman, he fails
at both. When a child tries to be an
adult, he fails at both. How goofy does
a child look trying to wear the clothes
of of a of his father of an adult? Looks
silly, right? What about an old man
wearing little little young young boy's
clothing wearing little short shorts and
a lollipop? What does he look like?
Looks goofy and silly. The only time a
person can fulfill his potential is if
he embraces what he is. you know, in our
time, and we'll end with this.
What is the message now? They're pushing
a lot of this this
this sexual
hypersexualized
agenda, especially on children.
And it's not good enough. Just regular
old Zena. Zena is is not enough. That's
boring. Now, now we need homosexuality.
We need all these different things. And
it's always the message of I have to
embrace who I really am.
Yeah. I always pushed away that part of
me, right? But I always knew I was
different. I always knew. I remember
standing in the schoolyard at five years
old and thinking, I'm not the other
boys. What five-year-old thinks? Tell me
this. This is this is a fantastical
story. I'm not the other
five-year-olds.
As if a child who grows up protected
from hypersexuality
will ever think about sex until he's
introduced to it.
A child who grows up in a good
environment has no idea how children are
made. Not until he's introduced to that
world. If a child is 5 years old
thinking about sexuality, this child is
being abused sexually. That's what that
means. That means that he is living in a
hypersexualized environment. Otherwise,
children don't have that. They're not
built with that. So, I had to embrace
who I truly am. Who are you truly?
Actually, a girl in a boy's body. Oh my
goodness.
This is the poison being poured into our
children's into our children's hearts.
And it all stems back from what? Trying
to make men and women exactly the same.
What they call equality. There's no
equality. Equity. Sure. Each one
being endowed with the exact tools
that they need to fulfill their part.
Sure. Equality,
communism
in in this sense, absolutely not. These
are the roles of the man and the woman.
And when these dynamics are off, what
happens?
There is no way that the marriage can be
successful in this way. One will have to
compromise a part of himself. Ether
either the man will have to start taking
on traits of a wife and the wife take on
the traits of the husband in order for
the balance to be restored. That's
that's how it works because it is
designed with one pilot and one
co-pilot. That's how this ship is fly.
This is how this plane is is flown.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]